nehmen sie jetzt drogen oder nehmen sie
keine die außenseiter diese frage hatten
unter den fingernägeln gewarnt und
deshalb ist ihm fragen lotto gelandet
seid also gespannt was sie antworten und
seid gespannt auf unseren nächsten gäste
und natürlich außenseiter und wer nichts
verpassen wollt von ihnen von hans
sarpei und bülent ceylan dann abonnieren
nicht vergessen
jetzt gibt's ja okay ich weiß bescheid
die grünen sind die netten die roten
sind diese nicht wie ich glaube jeder
einen gleichen rotes oder es ist glaube
ich habe aber nicht noch nie so ein ding
aufgemacht so du musst es am ende
abdrehen der oder wird auch
ok könnt ja auch richtig deutsch ich
glaube das ist offensichtlich oder
erhalten hatten
wir würden aber gerne aber er kenne
jetzt fahrrad fahren können
okay aber er trainiert ja wir wollen die
versuchen wir geben unser bestes auf
jeden fall ich meine so ich wohne jetzt
seit acht jahren oder sechs sieben acht
jahren in deutschland und so für die
zeit für die kurze zeit das ist schon
nicht schlecht finde ich also viel hat
er grammatikalische alles richtig dass
man schon mal sagen ja also es ist schon
schwer so mit 8 10 heran danach ein
fremdes in den trend das land zukommen
dann die sprache komplett neu zu lernen
dann war ich kann das auch mal das geht
einfach und ich glaube du machst das
kaputt oder
seid ihr wirklich so kreativ oder nimmt
er drogen okay
geschmäcker sind verschieden
wenn du glücklich bist dann klatsche in
der hand das war ein jahr auf ihren
namen tragen nein also es kommt es kommt
natürlich immer darauf an was man unter
kreativ versteht was ich schon kreativ
also für um mich zu begeistern und damit
ich sage das war kreativ ist auch schwer
ich habe daraus einen ganz komplizierten
geschmack aber ich glaube wir sind für
viele leute sind einfach kreativ weil
wir so immer irgendwelche ideen haben
aber ob sie kreative sind das ist
natürlich das liegt im auge des
betrachters
ok ich
nehme jetzt grün ok
so aber am ende abdrehen so wie ist das
so den meist abonnierten kanal
deutschlands zu haben das ist auf jeden
fall schön dass es natürlich ist geil
was soll man dazu sagen klar als klasse
ich war ich frage mich wie lange das
noch so bleiben wird es gibt noch viele
gute konkurrenz aber es ist cool
manchmal will man auch neu anfangen also
mein hier haben wir bock mit neuen namen
zwar bleiben wir der außenseiter aber
dann würden wir ganz anders heißen ja
stimmt also zum thema neue einnahmen
also es gibt es gibt also ideen die die
gar nicht auf den namen oder auf den
kanal die außenseiter passen würden und
da bleiben wir auch einige sachen aber
das heißt nicht dass die außenseiter
fasching geht also denke mal diesen
bescheuerten humor den behalten doch den
gibt es auch weiterhin aber vielleicht
dann in zukunft in zehn jahren fällt
nicht so oft nicht nicht so er nicht so
krass hast du noch eine frage
warum ausgerechnet düsseldorf
düsseldorf ist also eine modisch dadurch
wir wollten zuerst berlin wir wollten
sie das berlin aber wir finden in berlin
zu leben muss man sich noch verdienen
also wirklich dazu zählen das wollten
wir noch hamburg wollten wir von tu
berlin muss sagen sibirische kälte
das ist düsseldorf muss ich sagen dass
reden hier jeden tag uns hat keiner
gesagt dass regen und wirklich jeden tag
ja und zu der frage warum düsseldorf es
war echt eine ganz spontane entscheidung
wir wussten wir wollen in raum köln
düsseldorf nrw auf jeden fall und dann
haben wir gesagt okay wir gucken uns
wohnungen an
in der nähe von köln also wir haben
essen dann geschaut dortmund düsseldorf
kann also wirklich alles und wir haben
geguckt nach der lage die zu uns am
besten passen würde und werden in
düsseldorfer was für das gefunden wo wir
auch vielleicht ein bisschen versteckt
sind von leuten die uns die letzten
jahre so ein bisschen genervt haben
manche leute haben echt kein verständnis
und keinen kopf wir haben uns verfolgt
und gestoppt und das wollten wir nicht
haben und deswegen müsse laut
aber keine genaue adresse bitte wir
haben nichts gegen kinder wir mögen
können können ist toll also bei einer
frau
zusammen
mit einer schönen frau
hatte sich dort ist die letzte jetzt
worden das ist nämlich die grünen
bekommen ist also wie abtrennt hier
einfach abdrehen ja genau so sagen die
anderen
ja komm ich nimmt die rote
sie scheint auch so klein zu sein
wahrscheinlich sagen was wir die mal
warum bist du so kleinen oder sonst wer
sowas ganz kurz ist aber die sind jetzt
nicht rechts nicht wirklich wie es
gewesen also ganz viel
daran hätten per brief am schluss
nein wir sind nicht so die freunde ich
mag ihr schnitzel findet ihr das
eigentlich gut was ihr da so dreijährig
muss antworten zu meiner frage es war
viel spaß ich kann nur das sagen dass
uns spaß macht videos zu machen ob er
das gut finden es gibt bestimmte videos
die wir gut gefunden haben von uns die
kann aber nicht so gut an bei der masse
und die videos die wir selbst nicht so
gut finden die kommen komischerweise bei
der masse besser an als wir gedacht
hätten und im endeffekt im großen ganzen
finnen wäre das gut was wir machen weil
wir halt wenigstens ein hobby es ist es
ist schon gut ein eigenes hobby zu haben
und etwas sorgen wo man sagen kann das
ist mein ding das mache ich selber ist
das dann auch so ein bisschen bei euch
gesagt ja ich habe keine ahnung warum
ich sehr einfach gleich bin ich weiß es
auch nicht das ist schwer zu sagen es
kam einfach man ich glaube man kann auch
nicht so bestimmte tipps geben ok
schritt eins bis zehn musst du alles
durchgehen dann bist du so hast du so
und so viele abonnenten das geht gar
nicht zum glück zum teil ist es eine
glückssache zum teil ist das vielleicht
schon partie die sache zum teil ist das
richtige zeit zum teil sind das richtige
ideen zu da sind viele komponenten die
im großen ganzen dann alle zusammen nach
so bin ich wieder zu aus dem rahmen okay
sind viele sachen die einen dinge
ergeben
wieso seid ja so genial ich finde jeder
mensch ist in trogen ihren jeder mensch
also jeder mensch kann genial sein und
jeder mensch hat diese qualität in sich
drin es ist nur die frage ob er sie
entdeckt
ja also ich habe schon ganz viele
menschen die keine ahnung hat keine
100.000 abonnenten hatten keine eine
million klicks die kein haus hatten die
nicht viel hatten aber die waren genial
für mich da sind geniale menschen für
mich
wie zum beispiel menschen die früher
aufstehen und hart arbeiten oder fliesen
legen will fließen ist auch so eine
geniale kunst die habe ich auch gemerkt
ich guck mal gemacht und das muss man
auch gehen für mich ist das genial die
das überhaupt schnell so zusagt schön
aus ist auch für so eine frage genial
aber wie findet man das was man genial
gut kann indem man es liebt wenn du hast
lebst und verrückt und doch bist auch
wenn ist ein pornofilm minister oder
porno filme drehen dann macht das lasse
ich nicht beeinflussen von den von den
rest der welt
das ist auch die sache dass die jugend
heutzutage vielen leuten ich will das
nicht verallgemeinern aber vielen fehlt
halt so die motivation etwas etwas zu
machen worauf sie wirklich bock haben
viele machen einfach so irgendwas was
freunde machen oder wo man sagt okay das
ist cool wenn man so was macht aber so
ein eigenes ding zu machen wo es einem
richtig spaß macht so ein hobby zu haben
ist schon eine coole sache auf jeden
fall und ich wünsche es jedem der
irgendwas gerne macht dass er doch
weitermacht und das vielleicht auch
damit erfolge erzielt und
meine frage ist die letzte woher kommen
eure vielen ideen das ist auch eine gute
frage aber auch nicht schwerer ist es
schwer zu sagen woher sie kommen die
sind manchmal einfach plötzlich da im
kopf manchmal beobachten die unsere
mitmenschen wie ich schon gesagt habe
und man kann aus menschen vieles
rausziehen menschen haben so witzige
sachen sich weil wir lachen auch gerne
über uns selber wir gucken dann okay du
hast so die negative eigenschaft oder
die schwäche und das ziehen hier raus
und übertreiben das ein bisschen und
daraus entsteht dann wieder auch was
lustiges oder wie wir gucken was so
aktuelles gibt und dann denkt man sich
okay das ist so bescheuert das könnte
man korrigieren oder verarschen das ist
immer unterschiedlich aber die ideen
kommen und kommen kommen und die kommen
immer aber die alle umzusetzen die alle
umzusetzen das ja schwierig also wir
schaffen das nur die besten umzusetzen
wird wo wir denken das könnte gut werden
wenn wir alle versuchen würden
umzusetzen die ganztätige haben wenn wir
nicht mehr schlafen
sie sammelt ihr eure ideen ein ich habe
ich habe einen zettel neben schafft wenn
wir
manchmal also manchmal sind die echt
ganz spontan schalten die kamera ein und
treten einfach los manchmal überlegen
wir uns ag die und die schritte wollen
wir machen das schreiben auch ein paar
stichpunkte raus da drauf auf den sessel
und manchmal wirklich kompletten ganzen
text von einem video durchgeplant und
dies und das alles punkt nach punkte und
so muss es passieren wir wissen schon wo
ihr fehlen und wo das licht steht wo die
kamera steht und so weiter also erst nur
unterschiedlich manchmal sind wir auch
bleiben
ich habe schon gesagt manche sachen
total spontan und manche richtig
durchgeplant so was die parodien zum
beispiel sagt das ganze nicht spontan
machen den ganzen jahr herausgehen ein
bisschen um handeln ist da musst du
schon sich irgendwas überlegen bei den
letzten sachen dann auch schon einiges
konzipiert so konzepte gemacht und
das macht auch richtig spaß wenn du
irgendwo in so eine idee hast die du
auch versucht perfekt umzusetzen wurde
daraus selbst zufrieden ist aber das
funktioniert ähnlich wir müssen
natürlich auch zugeben dass hier keine
profis sind nach so vielen jahren immer
noch nicht aber
wir lernen lernen dazu werden auf jeden
fall dazu ich glaube die leute sehen
dass ich hoffe dass die leute sehen dass
es gibt spiele die immer noch sagen hier
werdet immer schlechter aber das haben
wir auch schon seit dem zweiten video
wahrscheinlich die dinge dass wir
veröffentlicht haben aber im endeffekt
ist eigentlich eine steigerung glaub ich
sowas göbel qualität angeht
super vielen dank ich bedanke mich auch
dann geschrieben
und wenn ihr noch mehr fragen lotto
zloty wir hatten latein gehabt sehen
wollt dann zum beispiel das mit alpa gun
der unter anderem sagt dass burschen du
ein guter politiker wäre oder auch
heftig diskutiert das mittel ali einen
der erfolgreichsten wie locker blogger
auf youtube ich bin geldgeil sagt er und
wie er das meint das sagt er eben in
franken lotto ansonsten bis dahin
programm